a five-story apartment building at the
crack of dawn hardly a military Target
and yet a residential part of Southern
Ukrainian separagia came under Russian
fire twice today leaving several
residents dead and many more injured a
horrifying reminder of Russia's
ruthlessness as War coverage had all but
shifted to Ukraine's Battleground gains
in the past weeks Putin's troops have
been pushed further and further out of
occupied territories with surprisingly
bold criticism of Russia's military
leadership growing louder by the day
gutted by Russian Rockets
here in zapparesia rescue workers
searched the rubble for missing
residents local officials say several
people were killed while more had been
hospitalized
after the initial Dawn attack
firefighters headed to the scene
but a second Salvo sent locals running
for cover
as well as rescue workers
president zielinski condemned the
strikes
after the first rocket strike today when
people came to pick apart the rubble
Russia conducted a second rocket strike
absolute violeness absolute evil
and there have been thousands of
instances of this already and there
could be thousands more unfortunately
locals were left reeling
why are they doing this to us
what are they trying to prove killing
old people
why for what
the attacks come as Ukraine continues to
force Russian troops back in the south
and east
with these Ukrainian troops in the
donbaths telling French reporters that
they were using shells captured from the
Russians
with winter fast approaching Kiev seems
determined to press its current
Advantage as long as it can
and we can now bring in Dr Jade McGlynn
she's a senior researcher at the
Monterey initiative in Russian studies
Dr mclin welcome back to the day Putin's
troops keep moving backwards with
Ukraine pushing further and further into
occupied territories are we at a turning
point of the war
we're certainly seeing the tide turning
in the war and as you say Ukraine's been
liberating more and more of its
territory 400 square kilometers of
Herson region in a matter of days and
the Russian army we've seen large
numbers of surrendering clearly it's
quite unable to get itself together and
yet while it's clear that Ukraine is in
a relatively relative to its earlier
position relatively strong position it
feels too soon to say exactly what this
Turning Point might lead to sort of what
road we are we are turning into I
mentioned earlier in your report we saw
that Russia launched strikes on
apartment blocks as people were sleeping
in the city of separation
which Russia claims as its own despite
not having defect in control and then in
light of Putin's comments later on in
the day that the situation in these new
territories as he would call them would
stabilize it's quite hard not to worry
that this is an ominous important of
what is to come
um and that's what always happens when
Russia's on the back foot as we've seen
in Syria and in chechnya in Ukraine in
2014 that it reacts by fighting harder
and uglier and with less concern that
for lives its own and others
these continued setbacks that we've been
seeing over the past weeks have
triggered an unprecedented wave of
criticism towards Putin's top brass I
mean the Russian installed head of the
occupied her son region even suggested
the defense minister shoot himself how
much credibility is this costing Putin
and his cronies
mm-hmm so first Ramos of the the Russian
installed um head of the Hassan region
um to say that shoiku um the ministry of
Adventure 2 himself is really just
beyond remarkable to to be witnessing
this sort of breakdown in discipline
normally these sorts of collaborators
you know they do as they're told they
pretend everything's fine but clearly
that's no longer tenable things are a
Breaking Point
um so your question of credibility is a
very pertinent one um clearly reality is
starting to bite through the The Mirage
though I would say that it's perhaps
still too soon to talk about it costing
Putin directly I think instead what
we're going to see is criticism of
officials and different people trying to
blame different people but but not
directly Putin yeah another one of the
very vocal critics of what is happening
on the battlefield was the infamous
church and leader ramzan kadirov he
accused the Russian military of
incompetence and nepotism and he now
claims that the Kremlin promoted him to
General what do you make of that
it would appear that he has been
promoted to general which I think is
probably a note of how much the Kremlin
wants to keep
um kadira inside the tent
um but you're quite right that alongside
um yeah for example founder of the the
Wagner group of the mercenaries they've
um together they've been ridiculing the
generals saying that the military's
riddled with nepotism that senior
officers should be sent to the front to
tone for their sins in blood
um and in terms of their accusations of
incompetence and nepotism I'm actually
for once of one mind with General
godirov I think he's correct the system
that Putin's created in Russia is one
that's riddled
um with incompetence with cronyism and
that really has ended up being making
the system is Future's Own Worst Enemy
it's why the military isn't as
modernized and it's wider military is
not doing as well but it's clearly all
that money didn't didn't go on on
modernizing the Army yeah
has been pushing for a more drastic
approach by the Russian army openly
pushing for the use of nuclear weapons
actually with increasing Battlefield
losses does that option become more
likely in your opinion
the show and honest answer here is that
I don't know
um and I don't think we can ever be
flippant about the use of nuclear
weapons
um though that said it's also not wise
to to sort of scare manga or to be seen
to give in to nuclear blackmail so it's
of course it's an incredibly difficult
one I think so far what we've seen is
that in general if one stands up to
Putin's threat without sort of being
deliberately escalatory then he tends to
give in so whether that's Sweden and
Finland joining NATO or Ukraine itself
fighting back or the US delivering High
Mars so
um whilst Russia likes to bring up is
nuclear superpower status
I don't think we should necessarily
interpret that as a Readiness to use
um nuclear weapons I think if that was
going to happen that we would start to
see certain activities rather than just
language and and thank God we haven't
seen that yet yeah in recent days we've
seen many Russian men who've been
drafted as part of this mobilization
complaining about the conditions they
live in that they're being sent into
battle without a second even of training
or instruction I mean that cannot be in
the kremlin's interest why is this
mobilization so chaotic
it is it's incredibly chaotic
um I mean I even saw um accounts today
of um people being told of men being
told to go and buy bicycle helmets
because they there were no military
helmets available and they were none
even to buy but I think the reason for
the chaos
um is because the Russian State itself
is so inefficient and sclerotic again
going back to that corruption we were
just speaking about the military the
bureaucracy quite clearly is not capable
of handling a large-scale mobilization
um of this kind and that's where the
chaos comes from now while all of this
is happening scores of ukrainians
continue to try and escape the war every
day and I want to talk about a specific
group of them that is stranded in
hostile Russia trying to cross into EU
country Estonia how did they get there
and what's their situation I know you've
been following it
yes I've spent a fair amount of time in
pascov region which is the region that
borders Estonia so
um I've been following this situation
quite closely there are of course very
long queues um up to five days in
horrendous and very cold conditions
which biscov residents are trying to
help with but um it's difficult the
delays come from the Russian side on the
main some of the people in this queue
not all but some of the quite a lot of
them are Ukrainian and there's a large
contingent for mariopol and they've
they've ended up they're largely um
after passing through
um filtrate so-called filtration camps
um which they were checked all because
the only way to escape the the shelling
the destruction of their city was
basically to flee into other areas of
occupied Ukraine and it's worth noting
as well that under occupation in Mario
upo most maripo residents became
convinced that there no longer is a
Ukraine so shut off are they from from
the outside world that you that Kiev is
um in smearings that everything is
destroyed and that they might just all
go to Crimea clearly learning that
that's not the case now quite a few of
them are trying to get back to Ukraine
by the EU or at least just to leave
Russia
desolate situation there Dr J McGlynn of
the Monterey initiative in Russian
studies always a pleasure talking to you
thank you so much for your time
thank you
the head of the international atomic
energy agency who's in the Ukrainian
Capital key for talks about security at
Europe's biggest nuclear power station
precisely in Zappa regia is discussing
plans for a safe Zone after months of
shelling near the facility the plant is
located near the front line in a
Southern Ukrainian region illegally
annexed by Moscow Russian President
Vladimir Putin ordered his government to
take formal control of the facility on
Wednesday but at a press conference in
Kiev grassy said it was quote obvious
that the station remained a Ukrainian
facility
I think ndw's Nick Connelly was at that
press conference earlier I asked him for
more on what Rafael Grossi said
well you had precious little detail to
give away at least in public for now
um he said he would be heading to Moscow
soon and then back to Kiev he was trying
to kind of spread optimism uh and make
it clear that he has not given up on
this idea of a safe Zone where there are
currently two of his colleagues in
zapparish at any one time at the power
station there they will soon be four but
I mean it's a drop in the ocean if you
kind of consider quite how many people I
work at that power station how big it is
and how major the challenges it faces
are given that you know this is Europe's
biggest nuclear power system station on
the front lines with Shilling going on
around every day basically
um but there was definitely a sense the
journalists wanted him to kind of take
sides and to talk about kind of Russia's
actions there the Russians attempts to
take control of that power station and
obviously given his U.N remit and the
fact he has to deal with the Russians on
a daily basis if he wants access that
power station he was keeping very clear
well clear of anything that could be
construed as a kind of political
statement now while Grassi was
discussing zephyrhia Russian missiles
hit separation killing several civilians
there is there something to be read into
the timing of this attack
I think definitely The Prodigy is one of
the Russians main targets they have no
legally annexed that whole region just
last week but you know the capital of
that region is still not under their
control it is under Ukrainian control so
there's definitely a sense that they are
trying to make things as difficult as
possible for civilians in Ukrainian
controls that but Asia to make you know
life without power without basic Heating
and other kind of supplies really
desperate to also put pressure on the
Ukrainian authorities there I wouldn't
necessarily say it was timed to coincide
with his visit but there is no sense
that Russia is somehow steering clear of
that power station or doing anything
that would kind of take away the risks
that that region is has been living with
since the beginning of this war now
we're talking a lot about the Ukrainian
counter-offensive and how successful
it's being what's the latest on that
we've heard from the Ukraine military
they didn't say that over the past week
they have taken back about 400 square
kilometers of territory in the ketson
region which is not very far away from
Asia just across the nepro river and we
are seeing you know that Ukrainian
offensive continuing the details can
trickle through to us quite slowly the
Ukrainian authorities are very careful
to make sure that nothing operational
gets out but there's a lot of panic on
Russian social media among military
bloggers and people who support this war
in a sense that you know they might soon
see a repeat of what happened a couple
weeks ago with the kind of total
collapse of Russian forces they are
basically out on a limb on the Western
Bank of the Nipper River with most of
the bridges taken out of action so they
are really really dependent on pontoon
bridges and airlifts to get supplies in
so there is a sense here in Kiev that
the Ukraine's Army is on a roll and we
are going to see more towns retaken by
Ukraine and more successes in the next
couple of days pw's Nick Connelly and
Kiev thank you so much
DW's Matthias Berlinger is in Eugenie in
southern Ukraine and I asked him earlier
what he was hearing about Russian forces
on the run from advancing Ukrainian
troops
we're hearing several stories of Russian
forces either running away or as uh or
or
surrendering to Ukrainian forces in
several parts of the Southern front
Ukraine has made big advances especially
in the Hassan region that's just
adjacent to the
zaporizia region and then every time
when these things happen the attacks on
the civilian infrastructure on the
cities behind the front lines on
Ukrainian territory support as we've
just seen today where seven Rockets hit
apartment blocks or on micro live or or
harkiv they increase that's usually the
response of the Russians when they start
losing territory it's a pattern that
we've been observing for some time here
now Russia has seized control of the
Japanese nuclear plant and president
zielinski is accusing Moscow of nuclear
blackmail isn't he
yes so the plant has been under Russian
control for several months now since the
beginning of the war effectively but
what has happened now is that Putin has
now formally as he signed a decree that
incorporates it into uh the Russian
State assets and and he has said that it
would be run by Russia now now what that
means is not very clear but it seems to
be that the Ukrainian stuff that is
running this plant uh is uh being
pressured to sign a new contract with
the Russian atomic energy Authority it's
a very complicated scheme that has been
uh allowed the the plan to function or
to be under more or less control
although there have been lots of
problems where the ukrainians would
continue running it while
um the command the command the the
leadership has been brought in from
Russia and now uh as yeah as Russia has
illegally according to most country's
assessment international law enacts
these territories they are now claiming
the station as part of their own the
Ukrainian side has told its Engineers
not to sign anything with the Russians
but this is of course a step of
escalation and that's why zelenski
called it nuclear blackmail because the
Russians being in control of this
station and fighting going on around
there is of course a dangerous situation
if I could just ask you quickly Russian
special forces are said to have suffered
significant casualties in the fight for
the key city of Le Mans how do you think
that will affect the morale of all these
newly mobilized Russian reservists
it's definitely not going to enhance the
trust in Russian capabilities we hear a
lot of uh information that the
mobilization is not going well very dire
conditions for the new new recruits very
bad preparation and this is definitely
not uh this is definitely adding to it
all right Matthias building in Eugene in
southern Ukraine thanks so much